hey folks Chris waters here to host
today's episode of gamespot news it's
Thursday June fourth and though III is
about ten days away pre three is in full
swing that's the term I just made up for
the fortnight before e3 that's now
become kind of a warm-up round four game
announcements and trailers all that
stuff to publishers used to save until
e3 but now they kind of got a roll out
now and it's probably painting me ask
for their marketing teams well their
burden is our boon so let's see what pre
free has for us today uncharted that's
what not the new one uncharted 4 but the
old ones uncharted is one through three
uncharted the Nathan Drake collection
will include drake's fortune among
thieves and drake's Deception all
rendered in 1080p and running at 60
frames per second it's being developed
by Blue Point games the studio
responsible for metal gear solid HD
collection and the ICO and Shadow of the
Colossus collection there are some
pre-order incentives predictably but the
bigger lure maybe the fact that bundled
in there will be first access to the
uncharted 4 multiplayer beta uncharted 4
was delayed to spring of next year but
the Nathan Drake collection is slated to
release on october 9th at macy's
nordstrom and other fine department
stores the Nathan Drake collection half
tucked all style remember all that Club
last year about steam machines and steam
controllers and steams inevitable
takeover of your living room your life
and your very soul those plans up or
seeding a pace you can now place
pre-orders for steam machines steam
controllers and steam link the small
device that lets you stream from your PC
to another screen in your house
pre-orders are planned to arrive on
October sixteenth and the stuff will all
go on sale regular style on November
10th a slick new trailer shows off the
features of the steam controller and the
thing looks freakin sweet ah but even
with all that beta testing they've been
doing I'm still reluctant to trust the
first iteration of new hardware what
about you folks are you excited for it
you think it'll live up to its lofty
ambitions have your
say in the comments below Gearbox
Software got in on the pre 3 parade with
a new trailer for battle born their
entry in the hot hot genre of shooters
that want to get some of them moba bucks
the video comes with a slew of details
about the game like it's got 25 playable
characters a story mode that you can
play solo or with up to four players by
a split screen or online co-op there's
going to be 3 multiplayer modes at
launch and a persistent progression
system all of which you can read about
in the full article on gamespot com
splashnews expect more battle born when
the clock tolls III last up some star
wars game news but it's not that Amy
Hennig visceral one and it's not
battlefront it's a mobile game Star Wars
uprising is pitched as an RPG that
allows players to create a unique
character in the classes of smuggler
bounty hunter rebel gorilla diplomat and
gambler it looks kind of like Diablo
it's set between Return of the Jedi and
the force awakens and it's made by
developer Kabam who has worked on mobile
titles in universes such as Marvel The
Hobbit and fast and furious it's gonna
be a big year for Star Wars so of course
some mobile games going to be a part of
that honestly I'd be surprised if it's
the only one with the movie out in
December and battlefront coming a month
earlier we're certain to see more of
Star Wars at e3 and as the year goes on
so where would you rate your Star Wars
excitement on a scale of like 12 rank or
how mad about a bantha I'd say and go
ahead and figure out what that means
I'll see you tomorrow right here on
gamespot news